so let's get even more practice solving
some exponential equations and i have
two different exponential equations here
and like always pause the video and see
if you can solve for x in both of them
all right let's tackle this one in
purple first
and you might first notice that on both
sides of the equation i have different
bases so it would be nice to have a
common base and when you look at it
you're like well 32 is not a power of 8
or at least it's not an integer power of
8 but they are both powers of 2. 32 is
the same thing as 2 to the fifth power
2 to the fifth power and 8
is the same thing as 2 to the third
power
2 to the third power so i can rewrite
our original equation as instead of
writing 32 i could write it as
2 to the 5th
and then that's going to be raised to
the x over 3 power
x over 3 power is equal to instead of
writing 8 i could write 2 to the third
power
2 to the third power and i'm raising
that to the x minus 12
x minus 12.
now if i raise something to a power then
raise that to a power i could just
multiply these exponents so i could
rewrite the left hand side as
to the
5 x over 3
x over 3 power i just multiply these
exponents and that's going to be equal
to
to the and now i just multiply the 3
times
x
minus 12. so 2 to the 3x
minus 36 and now things have simplified
nicely i have 2 to this power is equal
to 2 to that power so these two
exponents must be equal to each other 5x
over 3 must be equal to
3x minus 36 so let's set them equal to
each other and solve for x
so 5 x over 3 is equal to 3 x minus 36
let's see we could we could multiply
we could multiply everything by three
let's do that
so if we multiply everything times three
here we're going to get
five
x
is
equal to 9x minus what is this 9x minus
and now we can subtract 9x from both
sides and so we will get 5x minus 9x is
going to be negative 4x is equal to
negative 108.
we're in the home stretch here divide
whoops sorry about that
we could divide both sides by negative 4
negative 4.
and we are left with x is equal to what
is this going to be 27
x is equal to 27
and we are all done we're all done and
if you substituted x back in there you
would get 32 to the 27 divided by 3. so
32 to the ninth power
is the same thing as 8 to the 27 minus
12th power so 8 to the 15th
27 minus 12 8 to the 15th power so
anyway that was that was fun let's do
let's do the let's do the next one now
so this one looks
interesting in other ways we have
rational expressions we expect we have
an exponential up here exponential down
here
and the key realization here is well the
first thing i'd like to do let me put
this let me write this 25 in terms of 5.
we know that 25 is the same thing as 5
squared so we can rewrite this as
to the 4x plus 3
over instead of 25 i could rewrite that
as 5 squared and then i'm going to raise
that to the 9 minus x
to the 9
minus x
and that of course is going to be equal
to 5 to the 2x plus 5.
now 5 to the second and then that to the
9x 9 minus x i can just multiply these
exponents so this is going to be
5 to the 4 x plus 3
over
to the 2 times 9 is 18.
2 times negative x is negative 2x and
that is going to be equal to
to the 2x
plus 5.
and now let's see there's multiple ways
that we could tackle it we could
multiply both sides of this equation by
to the
5 to the 18 minus 2x that's one way to
do it or we could say hey look i have 5
to some exponent divided by 5 to some
other exponent so i could just subtract
this blue exponent from this yellow one
so the left hand side will simplify to
5 to the 4x plus 3
minus
let me just minus in a neutral color
minus 2x 18 minus 2x
and that of course is going to be equal
to what we've had on the right hand side
5 to the 2x plus 5.
now we just have to simplify a little
bit
let's see this is going to be in fact we
could just say look i'm having trouble
with my little pen tool
whoops
all right so now we can say this
exponent needs to be equal to that
exponent because we have the same base
and so
what we have here on the left hand side
that i can rewrite as 4x plus 3
minus 18
plus 2x i'm just multiplying the
negative times both of these terms so
plus 2x
is going to be equal to
2x plus 5.
so there's a bunch of different things
we could do here one we could subtract
2x from both sides
that'll clean it up a little bit 2x from
both sides we could also subtract 5 from
both sides so let's just do that
so
well
let me just subtract it subtract 5 from
both sides
i'm skipping some steps here but i
figure you're you're at this point
reasonably comfortable with linear
equations
so then
on the left hand side we are going to
have
4x and then you have 3 minus 18 minus 5.
3 minus 18
is negative 15
minus 5 is negative 20
is going to be equal to
zero
and then because those cancel out and so
add 20 to both sides you get 4x is equal
to 20
divide both sides by 4
and we get x is equal to 5 and we are
all done